- Des îles démocratiques et
libres à portée de main de
La ville de Xiamen se trouve
à moins de cinq kilomètres
des îles Kinmen.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici, les souvenirs
des bombardements chinois
Un peu comme ces piquets
anti-débarquement qui parsèment
des années 60.
♪ ♪ ♪
Un vieux char d'assaut rouillé
et de cette période d'extrême
tension.
10 ans lorsque les bombes
ont commencé à s'abattre
sur les îles Kinmen en 1958,
le privant de l'ucucuciance
d'une jeunesse normale.
Forcé de grandir tropdededededee
étététudes afin d'aider
sa famille. Il s'offre enfinquqs
chaque jour réservées à
son passe-temps : la recherche
de roches spéciales qu'il pourrs
dans le potager lorsque le
bombardements ont commencé
le 23 août 1958. Il se rapp l le
faits de boue et d'avoir fui
dans les montagnes,
loin de son village.trtrtrtrtrts
70, la Chine a tiré plus
Kinmen. Plusieurs musées
témoignent de la guerre et de
lors de ces attaques.
Des dizaines de milliers d'obus
chinois se retrouvent
maintenant ici, dans l'atelier
de Maestro Wu.
Né en pleine Guerre froide,
il a grandi so
bombardements chinois.Aujourd'he
ces obus en ustensiles et
la cuisine. Il peut forger
60 couteaux à partir
d'un seul obus.
C'est une façon po
tourner la page sur cette guerre
du passé. Chacun o o obus
transformé en ustensile est un
rappel que l
et qu'elle doit être préservée.
Une paix de plus en plus fragile
en ont témoigné les exercices
militaires de la Chine et
de Taïwan l'été dernier.
Des manoeuvres militaires qui
situation dans laquelle les île,
se trouvent. Même si la majorité
les tensions dont les médiasfon.
"Nous sommes pris dans un étau
affirme ce politicienininindépïn
est coincé entre la Chine et
être la ligne de front d'une
guerreisisis peut-être aussi
le canal de communication
entre toutes les parti         ♪
Les îles Kinmen ont quelque
chose d'atypique. Un monde
unique aux caractéristiques
taïwanaises, mais avec une
proximgégégéographique et
économique avec la Chine.
le continent sont encore plus
étroits pour beaucoup de
résidents.bababababababababababx
effectuaient la navette chaque
jour entre Xiamen, en Chine,
et Kinmen. Plusieurs commercesua
visite des touristes chinois.
Malgré les douloureux souvenirs
des bombardements, de nombreuxdn
entretiennent des liens avec
la Chine et en conservent
une opinion favorable.g g g g gs
loin. Malgré les horreurs
des bombardements par la Chine,
il ne se considère aucunTaïwana.
"Mes ancêtres sont originaires
de la Chine et je
territoire gouverné par Taïwan",
affirme-t-il, avd'd'd'ajouter
qu'il préférerait être dirigé
par Xi Jinpi
les forces indépendantistes
taïwanaises.
et Taïwanais partagent la même
langue et les mêmes racines.
Même si elle souhaite que le
elle croit que la réunification
t t t inévitable.
En fait, beaucoup de résidents
sont contre le communisme, mais
pas contre la Chine elle-même on
économie, précise-t-il. C'est
une importante distinction.
Wan Ling a longtemps partagé
cette opinion avant d'aller
étudier à Taïwan. Aujourd'hui,
nombre de ses amis sont Chinois,
elle se déclare fièrement
Taïwanaise.
que les résidents de Taïwan,
en général, en connaissent peu
sur la réalité particulière
Contrairement à la majorité des
ne s'empêchera pas de parler
de politique. C'est l'occasion
de communiquer avec des gens
et de faire changer les choses.
La communication pour prévenir
une guerre, beaucoup de
dont Maestro Wu, se rattachent
à e e espoir.ononononononononont
toujours le monde ordieee
comme vous et moi qui souffrons.
Les tensions dans le détroit
de Taïwan ne l'affectent pas.
Il a connu le vrai stress
de la guerre.
Il ne croit pas que la Chine
veuille vraiment attaquer
Taïwan, mais si elle le faisait,
ajoute-t-il, elle l'emporterait
facilement, ne serait-ceéééééééé
en provenance du continent.
♪ ♪ ♪
Si les souvenirs des
bombardements chs s s sont
encore solidement ancrés dans hs
îles démoiqiqiques et libres,
c'est sans doute pour rappeleros
la maue e e habitude
de se répéte